ça va moins chers et très bien très près
ce que vous ce week-end et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs il 18h42 je suis en
mesure de le dire vous avez changé
quelque chose
regardez bien chers téléspectateurs à
18h42 on démarre direct par un scoop
un scoop ce complot je vous demande et
dans l'hérault castaldi d'arrêter de
sourire bêtement et de regarder le
visage détendu
cette caméra vous allez regarder les
téléspectateurs pendant 10 secondes un
choral
on va faire à des comptes atteint 10 moi
je moi lui si ça
qu'est-ce qui la seconde sépare au début
j'ai trouvé ce qui là écoutez moi bien
chers téléspectateurs hashtag benjamin
castaldi a changé quelque chose
oui cela stein le plus long de
l'histoire azéma castaldi a fait quelque
chose car j'ai non seulement du piste
mais j'ai aussi de l'oeil et j'ai deux
yeux
un pourvoir et un pour détecter des
calicots castaldi tu as changé
il a changé quelque chose son visage est
plus tendue il est tendu comme un string
et du tout castaldi pas du tout est ce
que oui ou non
tu as fait des injections ce week end
whitman a donc on arrête en mesure de
vous montrer la nouvelle vision de
castanet lycée
[Rires]
oh
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui grâce à deux doublés
la france attend des réponses
la france attend la vérité frenchies
mois où se trouvait alors à lehman toile
j'ai agrandi un peu les paupières avec
toi bravo est les mecs
et vous croyez quoi vous croyez vraiment
kanu nador s'il vous plaît - a grandi à
paupières et agrandi paupières c'est
tout simple il ya un mec est comme ça et
tu te prends comme ça les îles comme un
coût et que ma coup c'est qu'ici tu
remontes c'est là tout va mais là ça
remonte vous faites ça trois fois par
jour vous avez les yeux cammas sur la
tête de ma mère c'est ce que font les
chouettes à elle échoué
benjamin est ce qu'on pouvait dire à nos
téléspectateurs ce qui s'est réellement
passé
allez tiens qu'est-ce qui a dit la
vérité mais je vous disais nous le dira
non bien c'est pas comme ça hervé temime
j'ai mis un petit peu a marre un peu là
pour que montre pas ma paupière se voit
se relève et le matin un peu là non
après du calme et du contact sexuel a
notamment fermé
ah bon je suis là bas c'est un marathon
c'est pas du botox
alors c'est le cas c'est bien ça l'acide
hyaluronique ouais c'est ça aux frères
détente et piccini venant juste amis de
la cible via une zone où les mâles
normales alors et qui cela fait donc ils
te mettre des petites piqûres ou sa
balle a ici ici donc tu as fait comme
une piqûre cbs the big ben pareil
maintenant sa durée j'ai passé à peine
dix minutes 10 minutes donc tu arrives
tu as dit les gars regardez l'arrivée
cabasilas bonjour castaldi on sait c'est
pour les yeux deuxième est ailleurs
à l'arrivée et là ya un gars qui est
arrivé et a mis des piqûres camatte
enlevé et toi t'as rien du mois jamais
on me fait ça moi même je fais pas mal
d'affaires il va être une nouvelle crème
à gaza et moi oui mais ouais mais la
crème quoi vous savez qu'on verra les
effets définitive dans une semaine en
une semaine ce sera carrément comme ça
dans une semaine et là des jumelages
dans une semaine le gars est pour voir
un gars est à 100 km
non mais sérieux et castaldi s'est
affichée en mai étaient mauvais comment
ça tu as payé non plus dans le cadre
d'un dany sanz marchandises toujours
pourtant une petite photo sur un stars
n'ont pas encore pas encore là temps
d'abord état final d'accord et comment
tu te sens mais beaucoup ce que ça fait
mal un peu c'est quoi ces faits pourquoi
c'est pour enlever les rides non c'est
non c'est moi j'aimerais moi j'ai des
repères qu'ils tombent là oui on peut le
dire qu'ils tombent ouais donc comme
gerber qui tombe
ouais en fait il fait dire ça remonte un
petit peu oui pour ces deux là
l'esthéticienne c'est ok on a la chance
et le sourcil oui et logiquement
regarder mais c'est joli
oui elle voudrait faire savourer